Quran says in Sur Bak CH 2 verse 188
that do not use your wealth as a bait
for the judges so that you may eat other
people's wealth bribing is prohibited in
Quran Allah says in the Quran inah isra
chapter number 17 verse number 26 and 27
that do not be a spendthrift do not do
is for verily a person who a Spen Thrift
is the brother of the devil
Allah says in the Quran which were
recited by
thear inat chapter number 49 verse
number 11 and 12 that do not
backbite do not call each other with
offensive nicknames do not spy on one
another do not be suspicious because
many a Time suspicion is a
sin and further it continues
recited 49 verse number 13 Allah
says which means oh
humankind we have created you from a
single pair of male and female and have
divided you into Nations and tribes so
that you shall recognize each other not
that you shall despise each other and
the most honored in the sight of
almighty God is the person who has
the criteria for judgment in the sight
of almighty God it's not wealth it's not
sex it's not color it's not cast but it
is tawa it is God Consciousness it is
righteousness it is
piety the only way that all the human
beings can come under one Banner is that
we have one common
parents and our
creator Allah subhana wa ta'ala almighty
God is one and the
same Islam is a religion of peace peace
to
humanity it does not only talk about
peace it
demonstrates
practically how peace and Universal bre
can be achieved and one of the pillars
of Islam is
Salah I say Salah is the programming
towards righteousness it's the best way
how a doctor tells you that for a
healthy body you require minimum three
meals similarly for a peaceful Soul you
require minimum five times prayer
and our beloved Prophet Muhammad sahi
wasallam said it's mentioned s bukari
volume number one in the book of Adan
chapter number 75 Hadith number
692 the prophet said before starting
Salah that straighten your rose stand
shoulder to shoulder and Ankle to
ankle it's
mentioned in the Hadith book of Abu da
volume number one in the book of Salah
chapter number 245 Hadith number 6 66
our beloved Prophet M before offering
Salam he turned around and said that
straighten your rose stand shoulder to
shoulder and Ankle to ankle and do not
leave any gaps for the Satan closing
your gaps so that the Satan doesn't come
in here the
prophet he was talking about the Satan
of cast of color of creed that when we
stand for Salah We Stand shoulder to
shoulder irrespective whether rich or
poor black or white yellow or brown king
or POA when you stand for Salah when you
stand for prayers we stand shoulder Tosh
shoulder we practically
demonstrate minimum five times a day
Universal Brotherhood and how peace can
be obtained and the best
example of international Universal
Brotherhood and
peace is the fifth pillar of Islam that
is Haj it's compulsory that every adult
Muslim who has the means to perform Hajj
should at least perform the pilgrimage
to the holy city of Makkah in the month
of Hajj at least once in his lifetime
people from different parts of the world
from America from UK from Singapore from
Malaysia from India from Pakistan
different parts of the world the men
that deskop in two pieces of unsown
cloth preferably white you cannot
identify the person standing next to you
whether it's king or a papa whe rich or
poor practical demonstration of
universal brother and this message of
peace is not only meant for the Muslims
or for the
Arabs Allah says that this Quran is the
last and final revelation of almighty
God and because it was the last and
final Revelation it was not only sent
for the Muslims or the Arabs Allah says
in Surah ibraim chapter number 14 verse
number one Al L this is a message given
to the prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him so that you may lead the humankind
from Darkness to light not only the
Muslims of the Arabs but the whole of
humankind from Darkness to light peace a
vision of Islam is not meant only for
the Muslims or the Arabs it is meant for
the whole of
humanity and for ultimate
peace I would like to end my
talk by the formula given in the Quran
for ultimate peace in Sur Al chapter
number 103 verse number 1 to3 which says
by the token of time man is well in a
state of loss almighty God says man is
in KAS is in loss except those who have
these four criterias only those who have
these four criteria will enter Jenna
will go to paradise Allah says first is
Iman Faith next is that is righteous
deed third is inviting people to truth
that is doing doing dawa calling people
towards the
truth and fourth is inviting people to
patience and
perseverance I side my talk by quoting a
verse of the Quran from Surah is chapter
number 17 verse number 81 which
says when truth is H in falsehood
falsehood perishes for falsehood is by
its nature bound to perish I would like
to end my talk with the quation of the
Glorious Quran of Sur Al Imran chapter
number three verse number 19 which
says Islam the only religion acceptable
in the sight of almighty God is the
religion of Peace by submitting your
will to Almighty
godd now we go on to the next part of
the agenda which is a question answer
session yes sister asalam alah my
question is to Dr Zak n uh in the
beginning of your talk you said about
the criteria of hijab the very first
point is clothing must cover the entire
body and it doesn't consist of the face
and the Hand till the V Should can or
cannot be covered please
clarify sister asked a question that
when I mention the criterias for
hijab and I always do in my talk the six
criterias and I mentioned that the first
criteria is for the woman the complete
body should be covered except the face
and the hands up to the wrist many many
scholar say this should be covered that
for I say in my talk now the question
she's asking me that which is right
should the entire body be covered or the
face and hands can be seen this is a
question which has troubled many
scholars and sages and we as Muslim
sister should follow Quran and the
Sunnah there is not a single
verse in the complete Quran nor is there
a single Hadith a
Hadith in any of the Hadith of the
Prophet we which says that the face
should be covered I'm aware that the
many scholars written books that face
should be covered that many scholars
have written that the face can be open
so in the criteria of the extent for the
woman according to my study the complete
body should be covered except the face
and the hands up to the wrist and this
has even been told by Nas
albani even he writes in his book of
fatwa and gives various had which shows
that at the time of the Prophet there
were lady Companions of the Prophet
sahabas who had the face un the sever
for example be pleased with him when
there was a collection and there was a
lady who took out a jewelry and was said
that she was a black lady there's
another Hadith when the companion say
that if you want to
see a woman who has been promised padise
look at that woman how could he
recognize that woman unless he had seen
a face and if you see my answer I've
given in the Islamic voice there are
various s had which show that at the
time of the Prophet there were lady
companions who did show their faces and
and this is also mentioned by n albani
but I'm also aware that the other great
Scholars like shik binas and shei who
say that the faith should be covered but
any authentic Scholars any salaf
Scholars what they say that any lady who
covers the face should not rebuke at
those lady who don't cover the face and
those who do not cover the face should
not rebuke at those who cover the face
so the scholars are divided but there's
not a single authentic Hadith according
to NAS albani who says that the face
should be covered there are various
Hadith in Abu da also when the sister of
Haz
AA when she com from the Prophet The
Prophet says now you have reached
maturity your complete body should be
covered except the face and hands up to
the wrist this is a m Hadith but
according to he supports it with and
says this Hadith which is M becomes so
he gives various Hadi which say that if
a woman wants to expose the face she can
so covering the face is not a it is must
if someone covers the face a woman
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah it is good I
will never object to it but what Allah
and his Prophet has not made the F No
Woman No scholar in the world let it be
anyone can make it f on any other
muslima So based on research and even we
have various research that we do in irf
and many I know it is common that the
woman should cover the face but when I
ask any scholar present to me any any
one single had in which it says that the
prophet commanded that you should cover
your face you'll not find a single and
there's neither any verse in the Quran
which says that the face should be
covered all the verses of Surah chapter
number 24 vers number 31 and Sur aab 33
verse number 59 it talks about jilbab
talks about the woman's body should be
covered it never talks about the face
being covered even Sur 24 vers number
says that the veil should go over the
bosoms but yet I also say that covering
the face is must it's encouraged it is
not a f so what the prophet and Allah
has not made F even I cannot make so
covering the face for a woman in Islam
is not F according to me yet there are
many scholars who say it should be
covered I say fine it is De
view since no one has presented me any
any verse of the Quran So based on that
sister all those ladies are covering the
face alhamdulillah please continue
please don't
misunderstand and I know that there were
at least about 17 ladies from a who came
out of which 14 were covering the face
alhamdulillah three W so the option is
yours it's not a f but if those who are
covering it is good keep on covering I'm
not saying you should not cover but
since covering is not F you cannot
enforce on any woman to cover the face
hope that answer the question brothers
please ask your questions is it right to
call Allah as God because God is the
masculine gender and goddess is the
feminine
gender the question that when we
translate Allah as God in English is it
right God is a masculine gender God is a
feminine is it right I do agree with you
brother that God is not the appropriate
translation of the Arabic word
Allah therefore we Muslims prefer
calling Allah by the word Allah instead
of God because I do agree that a person
can play Mischief with the English word
God if you add s to God it becomes God's
meaning a PR of God Allah subhana tala
has got no
PR says Allah and only if you add D to
God it becomes Goddess that means
there's a male God and a female God
Allah subhana wa tala has got no gender
is neither feminine he's neither
masculine he's unique if you add father
to God it becomes Godfather he's my
godfather there's nothing like Allah ABA
or Allah father in Islam if you add
mother to God it becomes godm mother
there's nothing like Allah Amy or Allah
mother in Islam Allah is a unique word
therefore we prefer calling Allah with
the Arabic word Allah instead of the
English word God but when certain
Muslims when they're speaking with
non-muslims who may not understand the
concept of Allah subhana wa ta'ala and
if they use the word God for Allah like
how I have done because many people out
here are non-muslims they may not
understand the concept of Allah so if we
translate Allah as God for the
convenience of those who don't know the
true concept of Allah there's no problem
but God I do agree with you is not the
correct translation of the Arabic word
Allah hope that answer the question
asalam
alaykum the brother is asking about the
DAT line there is a time difference in
the DAT line and he wants to know that
if he's on one side of the DAT line and
he has prayed Juma and he has crossed
over to the other side and if it is Juma
work
there it could be the same day so what
he has to do so he's got a non-muslim
brother who's asking this
question and he wants Dr Zak to answer
that as a question
that if a person is traveling and we
know that there a DAT line the DAT line
is such that it doesn't go through any
country it goes in the sea so if a
person has prad Juma Salah then he
crosses the date line and he goes on the
other side and then again Juma is there
so what should he do if a situation
arises where suppose for example if if
you have celebrated Eid so you have to
celebrate Eid with the people where
you're staying with so you've already
celebrated Eid and offered the E Salah
again when you come to a place because
you started Ramadan with those people
ended there now you come to a new
country for example in Saudi Arabia you
start your Ramadan celebrate Ramadan
celebrate Etc and then come again to
India where the Eid is approximately one
or two days later you need not again
offer the E Salam so if you have offered
a jum Salah and you cross the date line
and again Juma comes so there you need
not offer your jum Salah but the chances
of this is very less because the time
taken to travel is quite a lot you have
to go from this part of the world to
that part of the world but if it happens
if you have offered a Juma Salah you
need not offer your Juma Salah again
because that week Juma is already over
and if you offer also at that time it
doesn't become a like you can offer your
Z Salah so if you join the jum also
there's no problem point to be noted for
a traveler Juma is not f for a traveler
Juma is not far so if you're traveling
Juma doesn't become far on you even if
you miss it if you're in the plane or if
you're traveling not far on you so if
you pray alhamdulillah if you want to
pray Juma again also no problem you can
even pray the first Salah again like if
I offered my M Salah and again there's a
jamat there's a Hadith in which a person
did not join the jamat so Prophet said
that are you a Muslim he said yes why
didn't you join the Salah so he said
I've already offered so why can't you
offer again so when you can offer your
first Salah again you can even offer jum
Salah again there's no problem at all
but Juma is not F on a traveler hope the
answer the
question asalam
alaykum uh there's a sister here wants
to know the method of Salah is it the
same for the man and woman same for the
Shafi and the hanafi has a question that
is the method of offering Salah for the
man and woman the same for the shafii
the same our beloved Prophet M wasallam
said it's mentioned s bukari why am
number one the prophet said pray as you
see me pray the prophet did not say that
the women should pray separately or the
men should pray separately there's a
Hadith again inkari number one in the
book of Salah that the sahabas they
prayed the same way as the men prayed
there's no different type of praying for
men and women you should pray the same
as the prophet prayed irrespec whether
you are a man or a woman I am aware that
there are books available in the market
in India and throughout the world of
different schools of thought that the
style of praying for women is different
because they are seen and the men is
different there's no such s had for
reply in Islam always your answer should
be backed up with Quran and had always
Quran and had so whenever you give
reference any scholar let it be the
biggest scholar in the world if he gives
the answer there should be proof
quotation from the Quran and Hadith ask
him for proof
there's not a single there's no verse in
the Quran which says that the styles for
offering Salah is different for the men
and women I'm aware that Scholars of
their own view they said okay fine
because women should be protected they
should pay differently these are their
thinking but the prophet never said that
we should pray as the prophet prayed
regarding the style for offering Salah
as the Hani style and the Shafi style
I'm aware that it does differ the hanafi
they keep their hand below the nav the
Shafi keep the hand on the chest they do
they say I me loudly again my first
answer bukari the prophet said in Vol
number one in the book of Salah pray as
you see me
pray and all the fouras Imam Shafi imal
Imam Abu hanifah IM Malik all the great
four said that if you find any of my
fatwa which goes against Allah and his
rasool throw my fatwa on the
wall I'm aware Abu hanifah pleas with
him he are a great scholar I respect him
I love him
people say that he said that when you
offer Salah keep your hands below the
navl there's a Hadi in Abu
da if you read volume number one book of
Salah which says that the prophet kept
his hand below his NE when he offer
Salah but this is a immediately the next
Hadith says which is a Hadi that the
prophet kept his hand above the N there
are other
had in which say that the prophet kept
his hand on the chest so when there are
Hadith say the prophet kept on the chest
the Hadith below the NV is z so the
right way to offer Salah keep it on the
chest that doesn't mean everything Imam
Shafi is right or Imam abuan pleased
with them both that they're wrong see
they were great Scholars we respect them
they're great imas but we fail to
realize that at that time the Hadith one
compiled during the life of the Prophet
the Quran was compiled there's no
question at all and his own supervision
but the Hadith one compiled they started
being compiled later on 50 years 100
years 150 years later on so these
Scholars came earlier and because they
didn't have all the s had with them the
fatwas that they gave were based on the
knowledge that they had I don't think
that Abu made a mistake what he did
because that s had didn't reach him so
maybe according to me the Z reached him
and he may have said keep your hand
below the N the say Hadith may have
reached Imam Shafi he said that keep
your hand on the chest
again s bukari says Vol number one in
the book of Salah that you have ra ra
the prophet said not because IM Shafi
saying I'm following it because my
Prophet said it now in
wo there's a verse in the Quran in Surah
MAA chapter number five that it says
that when the woman touches the woodoo
breaks the Arabic word is Mas coming
from namas which means touch according
to IM Shafi be pleased with him he says
that if the woman touches the woodo
breaks Imam Abu hanifah said if the
woman touches a man who's in woodo woodo
does not break now the Arabic verse of
the Quran says L if the woman touches
woodoo breaks but there are two meanings
of masah one is a sexual touch and the
other is a physical touch so Imam Shafi
may Allah be peace with him he took it
as a physical touch Imam Abu hanifah he
took it a sexual touch so both had a
difference of opinion but when you go to
AB da number one in the Hadith of be
pleased with her the prophet was in
woodoo he kissed her and and the prophet
without doing woo again went for Salah
there's another Hadith inkari in the
book of Salah volume number one that AA
was sleeping prophet put the leg on
offer Salah so this Pro that physical TI
does not break the woodoo so here Abu
hanifah may Allah be pleas with him is
right and Imam Shafi not that he made a
mistake willfully that Hadi didn't reach
him so all were great Scholars and all
the said that if you find any of my
fatwa which goes against Allah and his
rasool then throw my fatwa on the wall
so I say that I I Dr zi why Abu
hanifah maybe give the fwa keep down
below the na while offering Salah but
the says keep on the chest so I have
offering Salah I keep off my chest I'm
AI Imam Shafi said if you find any of my
fatwa which goes against Allah throw my
fatwa on the wall so Imam Shafi said
that if the woman touches a man in Wood
wo breaks but says W does not break so
my woodoo does not break if a woman
unintentionally touches me so because
I've thrown the fwa of Imam Shafi on the
wall he said that I'm a Paka Shafi I'm
pah hanafi I'm pah Shafi I'm Paka hum
and was P Maliki Paka means TR I follow
100% other people follow 80% 90% or 60%
abif I follow total all the great four
IM said if you find any of my fatwa
which goes against Allah and throw my
fatwa on the wall all these Scholars
were great Scholars you have to respect
them but you have to realize that the
Hadith weren't compiled today every
everything on the fingertips on the CD
ROM in the books available so now the
scholars are there and out of lack of
information for example there my brother
who's a doctor and Copernicus Copernicus
was a great scientist but my brother has
more knowledge than cernas on science
even more than Einstein but Einstein was
more brilliant because today science is
Advanced that doesn't mean my brother
he's more genius than than Albert
Einstein Albert Einstein is a much
bigger genius than my brother but now
brother because hundreds of years have
passed he has more information about
science so information he has more but a
bigger genius is Al Einstein Isaac
Newton is Copernicus but today because
science is Advanced we have the
information with us so those Scholars
were great
genius we love them we respect them but
today the information has been compiled
so we have to realize as Allah says in
the Quran in Surah Al Imran chapter
number three verse
number3 hold the Rope of Allah strong
and be not divided we should not divide
our El into all sex so the only way of
offering Salah is not Hani style or
Shafi style or Maliki style it is the
style of the prophet and IM Abu pleas
with him Shi pleas with him they told if
you find anything of my fatwa which goes
against Allah throw my fatwa on the wall
so if you're PFI you have to offer as
the Hadith says if you're a Shafi offer
as what the had says then you'll be
following the true Islam hope that
question brothers please ask your
questions relevant to the
topic sir my name is Kumar Swami
hariharan my question is to zahi n
sir one of my friend purchased the Quran
and came to my
room I was so interested and
uh just I went to have a look of
it
immediately he told me that this is the
holy
book since it has been written by
the god directly you should not
touch till the date
whenever I am moving to his
house till now I am not touching
it is it
the right or wrong I don't know since he
is
following
correctly and one more question
sir and another friend this time is
moving to his house
for celebrating the
ramjan he told hello hariharan I am
moving so by hearty love I went to hug
him then immediately he told no no you
should not hug
then I asked him whether today is the
day we should not hug I don't know about
it that's why I asked today is the day
we should not hug then he told no you
should not hug at all to a
Muslim this is the another friend I
asked then he told no it's wrong answer
you you can hug from that time whenever
I am hugging I feel myself guilty and
shy I am doing the wrong thing please
clarify my doubts sir the brother has
asked two very important questions two
great
misconceptions the first question of his
was that one of his friends said when he
went to touch the Quran no you cannot
touch the Quran this is the word of
almighty God Is it true that non-muslims
can't touch the
Quran there is a
misconception as this conference is not
only for the non-muslims as said it's in
for the Muslims there's a misconception
amongst the Muslims that a non-muslims
cannot touch the Quran and this
misconception is based on one verse of
the Quran of Sur chapter number 56 verse
number 77 to which says that this Quran
has been revealed by Allah subhana wa
ta'ala and None Shall touch except those
who are pure now based on this verse of
the Quran many non-muslims they assume
that the Muslims are pure non-muslims
are impure they cannot touch it this you
should know the nul Quran when was this
verse revealed this verse of the Quran
was revealed when many non-muslims
objected and said that Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu Ali wasallam knowah he gets
this Revelation from the satans so then
this verse was revealed that None Shall
touch except those who are pure talking
about the Quran of if you
read it gives the clarification that
this is talking about lus the Quran
which is there in the seventh heaven
None Shall touch except the Angels the
Arabic word there mutar mentioned refers
to the angels not only pure and body but
those who are sinless yes so that Quran
which is in lus None Shall touch except
the Angels so if a Satan wants to pick
up these parts of the Quran he cannot
come close to it it doesn't refer to M
Tara which we talk about Wu if this
verse really means None Shall touch
except those in woodoo any non-muslim
can purchase a Quran for 150 rupees and
touch it and the Quran will be proved
wrong so this verse doesn't talk about
the voodo it talks about the
L which None Shall touch no human being
can also touch except the angels and I
always encourage that the best book you
can give the best message is the message
of Allah subhana wa ta'ala my speech is
useless what human being can explain
better than Allah subhana tala Creator
we have to share the message of the
Quran and there are some people who say
brother Zakir okay fine give only the
translation not the Arabic I said fine
okay that also you want to give give at
least but I prefer giving along with
Arabic why because in the translation
they can make a mistake if the mistake
is that it can be attributed to Allah
subhana tala wrongly and falsely for
example some of the Udu translation say
of Surah lman 31:34 that no one besides
Allah knows what is the sex of the child
in the mother's wound if a non-muslim
who has medical knowledge today with
alra sonography we can easily come to
know what is the sex of the child I
being a doctor I know that the
translation is wrong nowhere does Allah
use the word sex what Allah says no one
will know what is in the move of the
mother talking about the nature of the
child whether the child will be good or
bad whether he'll be ban for society or
Bo for society whether gur jna or Janam
hell or Paradise no one knows all the
scientists with the best equipment they
cannot predict this so the translation
is a mistake so if you give the Arabic
text anyone who knows Arabic can testify
that the translator has made a mistake
not Allah subhana waala I personally
prefer giving along with Arabic text and
if if Allah subhana tala holds me
responsible I'll be in good company you
know why because the Beloved Prophet
Muhammad sallallah Ali wasallam he when
he gave the message to the non-muslim
Kings he dictated ay of the Quran to the
sahabas and one of such of the letters
is already present in kopak musum in
turkey and there Muhammad sallu Ali
wasallam he had dictated the ver of the
Quran of Al Imran chapter number three
verse number 64 which
says say oh people of the
book come to comment terms as us and you
which is the first
term that we worship none but
Allah that we associate no partners with
him that we erect not among ourselves
Lords and Pat other than Allah if then
they turn back say witness that we are
Muslim is bowing to Allah subhana tala
Prophet Muhammad Sall Ali wasallam
dictated letters containing vers of the
Quran which were given to non-muslims
many non-muslims you know some of them
accepted Islam alhamdulillah some told
the letter some even trampled it beneath
their feet Prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam giv verses of the Quran
to a non-muslim he tamples it beneath
his
feet so brother there's no problem at
all you being a non-muslim you can read
the Quran we Muslims we sit like cobras
on the Quran it is not our property it
is everyone's property it is Allah
subhana tala is revealed you can very
well read the translation thank you read
the translation if you think something
is worth accepting accept it if you have
any queries you can ask the person who
has knowledge on the Quran you can touch
it there's no problem at all if anyone
says that why can't Muslim touch you ask
him for proof there's no verse in the
Quran or no Hadith which says that you
cannot touch now coming to a second
question that can a non-muslim Embrace a
Muslim or can a Muslim Embrace a
non-muslim brother alhamdulillah there's
no problem at all our beloved Prophet
Muhammad sallallah Ali wasallam he
embraced many non-muslims our SA
irrespective whether they black or white
rich or poor yellow or brown king or
poer there's no problem alhamdulillah
this is good it shows Universal
Brotherhood there's no problem at all
brother embracing you can very well
Embrace a Muslim can Embrace a
non-muslim A non-muslim can Embrace a
Muslim there's no verse in the Quran
Hadith which say that Muslim nonm Muslim
can't Embrace this is a misconception
your Muslim friend he does not have
proper knowledge of Islam that's why I
might have told you out of ignorance but
in Islam you can very well Embrace
there's no problem thank you very much
sir brother harar please come to the
stage Dr Zakir n will present him a
translation of the
Quran you can say that Zak Nik himself
has given me a translation of the
[Applause]
Quran we are running out of time
I think we will take one more question
and uh inshallah we will conclude asalam
alikum my name is Shakil Ahmed I own a
gold of say 100 G this year and I pay
zakat this year I carry forward that
gold of 100 grams to next year do I have
to pay a zakat next year also for this
gold in addition to whatever wealth I
earn the next
year the brother asked this question
this question can only arise in Madras
and Chennai no
Wells I'm aware that there is the
controversy some person who has said
that zakat if paid once in the year you
don't have to pay again in the next year
there is no such Hadi of Beloved the
very had which says that zakat has to be
paid 2 and a half% above the nisab level
85 gram of gold and there are various
Hadith Omar pleas with him he said all
those who have not paid
zakat I will see to it that they pay
those have already paid last year the
are various had with mentioned
inkari with him he said those who do not
pay zakat again again means they already
paid before and I know this controversy
arised when Dr Bal Phillips also was
here in a trip to Chennai I'm aware that
he wrote a book giving proof that zakat
should be paid every year if you lose
that gold if you don't own it then you
have to pay if you own it every Luna
year it is every Luna year if you own it
for one year minimum you have to pay if
you have that same goal with you for
next year again you have to pay every
year you have to pay
2.5% of whatever savings you have above
theab level hope that answer the
question one more question from the
sisters sisters please there are sisters
waiting asalam alaykum I would like to
ask you if a woman has such a pivotal
role in Islam why is that she's
prevented from interacting men and today
is extremely competitive world I mean
how without interacting with men writing
for competitive exams and appearing for
such you can stop yourself from growing
this is all the question today is a
world of competition without women
interacting how can they compete in this
world Etc sister Islam is the religion
which has uplifted the woman and
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam is
the major benefactor there's not a
single rule in Islam which prevent the
upliftment of the woman but in the name
of
upliftment Islam does not believe in
degrading women if you see history
sister history of Babylon history of of
Greek history of Egypt civilization
women were only used for sex and
pleasure and today if you see the
Western World the Western Society
talking of uplifting the woman have
actually degraded her to a status of
mistresses of concubine of society
butterflies which are mere tools in the
hands of Pleasure Seekers and sex
marketers today the Western Society
talking about women's liberalization it
is nothing but a disguised form of
exploitation of a body of degradation of
an honor and deprivation of a soul
sister Islam never never wants to
prevent the women from upliftment but I
don't know of a single job or a single
competition in which a woman does not
interact with men and she cannot Advance
all the jobs which involves unnecessary
interaction of the men aren't jobs which
are fit for the women to be done there's
not a single modest job which I know
which
prevents the woman about the modesty
role if there's a job any job which
prevents you from doing the hijab hijab
not only of the body not only of the
clothes the way you talk the way you
behave the you think all this comes on
the hijab this hijab which I spoke
earlier about the hijab that the sister
asked me that's one part of hijab that
is a clothe there are Hadith in which
the wives of the Prophet they did cover
their face but everything what the
prophet did is not F similarly for the
wives of the Prophet because
the they were mothers of the Believers
for them was a different degree so they
did Cover the face but it's not F all
the women so here if you analyze sister
the hijab besides hijab of the clothes
the hijab where a person talk the way a
person behaves and these people when
they talk about equality when the
Western World talks about equality I
asked them that when men and women are
equal so why don't you have a boxing
match between the men and women together
why they're equal even they agree that
they're not
equal when you have 100 meter sprint why
do the women run differently why do the
men run differently why are they
degrading the woman yes or
no so you realize that these people they
have their own way of thinking Allah
subhana wa ta'ala has made the man and
woman different physiologically they're
different biologically they're different
psychologically different depending upon
the roles what they have been given
Allah subhana wa ta'ala has given the
dos and don'ts for these people not that
a man woman cannot interact unnecessary
interaction is to be avoided and believe
me sister a woman can take
part we have example and if you hear my
talk on women lights in Islam sister
there are various examples now in the
Western World when they sit for
examination men and women sit together
so there they consider them equal but
when they run a 100 meters Dash or have
a boxing match they don't consider them
equal when the Western World can
differentiate that here they can take
part together here they cannot take part
why can't our creator Allah subhana tala
who knows the best so unnecessary
interaction sister I call it thean Allah
says in the Quran inah Bak chapter
number 2 verse number 168 Allah
says oh you believe do not follow the
footsteps of the devil see most of the
places Allah says do not follow the
footstep of the devil do not follow the
devil is right that's only a couple of
time majority time Allah says do not
follow the footstep of the devil and I
give example sister one example of
footstep of the devil is that suppose
there's a average
Muslim if a lady comes to him and says
let's spend the night together you say
spend the night Haram not allowed he
will say no the same Muslim who the
average Muslim if a lady phones speaking
to a girl on the phone what's the
problem so he speaks to the girl on the
phone after a few calls he said let's
have maybe tea in McDonald's or Kentucky
Fried Chicken I don't know they Madras
or not or let's go to fast food joint
going with a girl to fast food joint no
problem after some time she says let's
have dinner in a restaurant dinner with
a girl restaurant no problem then she
said let's spend the night together
spend night together no problem these
arean it's not mentioned in the Quran
I'm giving my own example Shan so
therefore stop it at the first level
itself when it's a requirement when you
have to speak to the man when
requirement in emergency Etc yes you can
do with lowering your
gaze suppose you're a lady and you get
sick and there's a gen doctor very well
you can go to the Gen doctor that
doesn't mean you cannot speak to the Gen
doctor when required but with lowering
your gaze with modesty but unnecessary
gossiping what they have in colleges in
colleges they gossip very common not
only the Western World in Western world
according to the statistics of USA more
than 90% of the women before they pass
school they have lost their
virginity do you know that same in UK
even in Bombay I was shocked more than
50% of the girls before they pass the
school they lose their virgin I was
shocked why common having girlfriend
boyfriend you go you know it's common if
you don't have a girlfriend then you're
considered to be
abnormal so the thing is Sister these
are and we want to uplift the women and
these people in the name of trying to
uplift the women art and culture no
problem they want to sell their
daughters and the mothers on the screen
and someone told me one of the ads which
won an award the BMW ad somebody told me
the BMW ad it's a car which is very
famous for the youngsters like how
Mercedes you know MC a very famous car
for the youngsters it's a BMW they're
very famous ad someone told me there's a
girl standing on a bon in front of the
car and it says test driver now who the
girl of the car what are they doing
they're selling our daughters they are
selling their sisters we Muslim we don't
want that in the name of upliftment we
we don't to sell our daughters don't to
sell our sisters we respect them we love
them and We R them this is the reason
sister this does not degrade the woman
It app the woman hope to answer the
question my name is Abdul kudus I got
one small
question sallahu alaihi wasallam in many
hadiths he has said there's
a punishment in
the for the dead bodies punishment in
theab
but how about people who are not buried
in the hab what type of punishment they
get and how do they get it where do they
get itam alikum the question that theith
is there for Prophet wasam that in the
there is there reward the punishment is
there there known as Barak Barak means
interim life after a person dies and
before he's resurrected it's a Barak an
interim life so if those who are not
buried what about them see when the
prophet said in theab means after after
a person dies and before he resurrected
if a person drowns and dies there yet
he's dead if a person is burnt alive and
a fire or there are various other
religions who burn even in this case
before the person is
resurrected after he's dead before he
rected if Allah wants to give him
punishment he'll get the punishment if
Allah wants to reward he will reward him
that doesn't mean that he has to be
physically present underground that this
thing can take place that will yet take
place and Fin recompense will be the day
of judgment Allah says in the Quran Al
Imran chapter number three verse number5
Allah
says every soul shall have a taste of
death but the final recompense will be
on the day of judgment so when you lead
this life this life is a test for the
year after according to Surah M chapter
number 67 verse number two but you may
get part punishment here you may not get
you may get part reward here you may not
get part maybe in the B but the final
the final judgment will be when you
resurrected and that will be the true
Jud and he's Malik he is the master of
the Judgment hope to answer the question
brother
please please identify yourself I am n
from Bangalore
Karnataka I pray
peace I love Muslims and the
preaches but
in country like India
multi- religious
country we all live
together and go for a
peace and for the
Brotherhood
but according to the current current
conditions what is your message for
Brotherhood it is my request to Dr Jakir
can you uh introduce yourself please
your name please brother
m i n from Bangalore Karnataka social
worker actually he's MLA from kataka
brother we love you too we love you
too as a question that in this place of
turmo said what's my message about
Brotherhood and I did say in my talk
brother I did give a few points that
Islam means peace to humanity it is a
religion of universal Brotherhood
that we believe that all human beings
are brothers in Islam all human beings
are brother irrespective of the black or
white rich or poor whether born in Hindu
family or Christian family we are
brothers humanity and Muslims are
brothers in faith but all the human
beings are brothers and for this
Brotherhood as I mentioned my talk
brother the only way the best formula
that all human beings can come together
under one umbrella is to realize that
our creator our Lord our almighty God is
one and this is a message not only given
in the Quran it is given in all the
major scriptures of the world if you
read the Hindu scriptures it's mentioned
in bhagwat Gita chapter number 7 verse
number 20 it says all those whose
intelligence has been St my material
desires they worship Dem Gods it's
mentioned in the chandad chapter number
six section number two verse number one
it
says it's a Sanskrit quotation which
means god is only one without a second
it's mentioned in the Shar
chapter number six verse number n it
says of him there are no parents he has
got no Lord Almighty God has got no
mother he has got no father he has got
no Superior it's clearly mentioned in
the chapter number 32 verse number
three of him there is no likeness he has
got no images and the Brahma Su of
Hinduism
is there is only one God not a second
not at all not at all not in the least
bit this is the same message given in
the Quran in surlas chapter number 112
verse number 1 to4 which
says say he's Allah and only Allah Allah
the absolute
Eternal he begets not nor is
begotten there's nothing like him
brother this is also mentioned
Christianity I can with quotations from
the Bible I can with quotations from the
six scriptures all the scriptures says
God is one God has got no images he
alone should be worshiped he has got no
Sons he has got no mother he has got no
father so if all the human beings
realize that our God our creator is one
then only can we have the true
Brotherhood besides this there's no
other formula and as I mentioned my talk
and which the beginning of the talk
chapter number 49 verse number 13 which
says
which means oh humankind we have created
you from a single pair of male and
female and have divided you into Nations
and tribes so that you shall recognize
each other not that you shall despise
each other and the most honored in the
sight of Allah subhana wa ta'ala is the
person who has tawa the criteria for
judgment is not sex it's not color it's
not cast it's not wealth but it is God
Consciousness it is piety it is
righteousness so we have to realize that
we have got one common grandparents
and we are a big Brotherhood so the best
thing is we should read other people's
scriptures and come to Common terms and
based on the verse of the Quran of Al
Imran chapter number three verse number
64 which
says come to come in terms as us and you
which is the first term Allah that we
worship none but Allah hope the answer
the question
no